Let's go through this one in parts.
Any regular expression starts with r' or r".
I'm going to use the single quotes this time so that I won't have to escape
quite as many of these.
Then we want to match the blue " here at the beginning,
and somewhere way at the end, we'll want to match the closing one,
and that will be the end of our regular expression.
So now we just have to think of what goes in here in the middle,
and this may not be enough room. I may have to erase it and write it again.
Now whatever it is, it's going to be 0 or more of something,
and as we're going across the string, there's sort of backslashes,
which are important, and everything else, which is not so important.
So if there's any character that's not a backslash,
and here I'm escaping the backslash,
we can just read right over it--that's no problem inside of our string--
or you could actually have an escape sequence, like this \".
That looks like a literal backslash, followed by anything, and then it's done.
So let me just diagram this a little more.
Say this opening quote is 1, that matches things like this opening quote in the string.
Then in here, we have anything that's not a backslash--that's 2.
That's I-space-say-s-a-y-comma,
but then eventually we do get to a backslash.
Over here, we have a 2-character sequence that's a backslash followed by a dot.
These 2 characters--the backslash, followed by the quote--they are 3,
and then we're back to matching 2's--h, e, l, l, o, dot.
Now we have another backslash and a quote, so these 2 together will be another 3,
and then this part at the end is number 4.
So I have 0 or more copies of my string body.
The elements of my string body are either normal characters
or 2-character escape sequences.
All of this looks like 3 characters. It's really just 2.
I have to escape the backslash.
As a minor aside, after the Beatles and Sound of Music examples from above,
you may not be surprised to know that a number of English songs
of enduring popularity--ABC 123, BINGO--seem to have a regular expression sort of feel.
Repetition is very common in songs, and you get the same thing out of it
that you get out of a regular expression,
a concise notation versus in choruses, but then when you expand it out,
it takes a long time to sing.
However, there is 1 song that is actually too complicated for regular expressions--
the dreaded 99 Bottles of Beer on the Wall.
If you actually want the counting to work out correctly--
99 to 98 to 97--we can't fit it in a regular expression framework.
We'll have to return to that later, and eventually we'll be smart enough to sing this song.
For more info on this, Don Knuth, the computer scientist has written an essay
on the complexity of songs.